you were forced to make creative
decisions based on the rules that you're
given which is like you can't go back
and just do the same tricks over and
over even the same looks
[Music]
[Applause]
first and foremost those two movies gave
me my initial relationship with James
Juan to watch James and Lee
re-invigorate the genre move the genre
forward and challenge themselves from
the guys who created saw to come back
and really turn this world on its head
it was something about the first
Insidious movie where because we're on
such a shoestring budget shot over 20
something days you were forced to make
creative decisions based on the rules
that you're given which is like turn off
the lights that's the further in camera
practical scares on a modest budget all
those things that I really learned from
acting in the movies so it was a lot
more about just the concept of how these
Insidious movies work that I think
really reflect and probably in how I
approach this one
thank you
you can't go back and just do the same
tricks over and over even the same looks
even the budget of the first Conjuring
film it was a whole different ball game
from what we had on Insidious movies and
there's an expanse to The Conjuring
franchise just simply because of money
and time even Lee one else said to me
about this movie is that you know it
felt bigger than other Insidious movies
and I think a lot of that is my scope of
a film is not to keep it
tiny you know I want to be efficient and
a lot of this does take place in his
dorm room and those actions but I knew
with two people with different coasts I
wanted different looks I wanted daytime
and night time
um I I wanted different feels this movie
is a little more expansive and I think
that's what you know Conjuring taught me
that well sometimes it's great to get
down and dirty and do a movie in a
couple weeks it's also nice to have time
certainly to be able to build out scares
and which really have to be your set
pieces that Define your movie
I just emailed with David the other day
I mean that's still one of my proudest
movies I think the efficiency that
doesn't sound like a very creative word
but after you've directed it's an
incredibly valuable word we shot hard
candy in 18 and a half days I didn't
even know you could do that I had come
off of two Phantom of the Opera and the
Alamo both these just massive movies to
me that were six months at a time and
all of a sudden it's you're gonna shoot
this whole thing in 18 and a half days
and it was David's first film what the
movie lacked in expanse and maybe even
coverage and time he made up on the back
end with his color palette I think one
scene maybe was cut I mean he was so
efficient and lean in what he needed to
make his story his efficiency of
shooting and color palette was something
that I certainly admire to this day
one of the things that I always loved
about Stephen King that I think as a
real through line with Insidious is
having a very dark undercurrent of some
kind of emotional or family distress and
then completely going balls to the wall
wacky Supernatural
strange from outer space aliens in the
same film I really love that I think
this genre supports that and no one
writes that better than Stephen King
what insidious is is having this very
core of this family and in my movie this
family dealing with the trauma of nine
years ago that's why I didn't mind
taking these very uh melodramatic turns
in the final act because the Insidious
World warrants that I think it's okay
and Insidious wouldn't have done it in
The Conjuring different kind of thing
often actors and storytellers certainly
from the theater they run from words
like camp or melodrama I think the
supernatural element of it is important
to the Insidious World James really dug
into like Carnival souls and some you
know even his makeup design and that and
while I didn't really do that I
certainly feel an influence of Stephen
King the painting at the end to me I
just felt like sure yeah let's do
something really bold and strange and
also I had to confine it into a space
for time and every everything else so I
was actually trying to think of sort of
the Stephen King element that make
really like it and those stories so
spectacular to start with something very
basic and real and brutal and then just
go completely into another world I think
horror allows that specifically Stephen
King or and that's something that we did
certainly with in The Tall Grass you got
to just Dive Right In you know Touch The
Rock
[Music]
foreign